التوجه بالشكر لقطر على موقفها المسؤول
[موسيقى]
عقدت اجتماعا مهما اليوم مع رئيس الوزراء
القطري في كييف وكانت مباحثات مثمره
للغايه والاهم من ذلك اما قطر ستكون معنا
في تنفيذ صيغه السلام
[موسيقى]
كما ناقشنا وضع مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود
من المهم جدا الا يكون هناك نقص وازمات
تثيرها روسيا في سوق الغذاء العالمي
[موسيقى]
وجه سمو الامير بالاعلان عن تعهد بمبلغ
100 مليون دولار للمساعده في التخفيف من
شده الوضع الانساني في اوكرانيا
وتعهد الذي تقدمت به دوله قطر عبر التوجيه
عبر صاحب السمو بتخصيص مئه مليون دولار
لدعم اوكرانيا من خلال المشاريع الصحيه
والتعليميه والمشاريع المرتبطه في المياه
ونزرع الالغام وغيرها من المشاريع
الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
كما تعلمون كان دائما مؤيدا لحل السلمي
لهذه الازمه في اسرع الاجار وتتنيب
المدنيين تبعات هذه الازمه على الارض ما
تمثله هذه الازمه من التاثير على الامن
السميه العالميه وعلى
الامن الغذائي وامن الطاقه في المنطقه وفي
العالم